?
THE REALLY INTERESTING QUESTION.
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION WE ARE
HONORED TO BE JOINED BY SOMEONE
WHO HAS BEEN THINKING ABOUT THIS
FOR AN AWFUL LONG TIME, THAT IS
GLENN GREENWALD WHO WRITES FOR
SOME STACK, HE HAS BEEN COVERING
THE NATIONAL SECURITY STATE FOR
DECADES, WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE
THEM JOIN US NOW.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
AS JUST NOTED, YOU HAVE BEEN ON
THE TRAIL OF THE NATIONAL
SECURITY STATE LONGER THAN MOST
PEOPLE THOUGHT IT WAS ANYTHING
MORE THAN CONSPIRACY THEORY AS
WE NOW SAY.
WHO DO YOU THINK IS ACTUALLY IN
CHARGE OF THE GOVERNMENT AT THIS
POINT?
>> IT'S BIZARRE BECAUSE THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY BROUGHT US SO
MUCH EVIDENCE SHOWING US WHO
WAS, ONE OF THE VIDEO CLIPS WAS
WHEN CHUCK SCHUMER WENT ON TO
THE RACHEL MADDOW SHOW, HE HAD
POSTED IN THE CIA FORGETTING
IRAQ WRONG AND CHUCK SCHUMER
SAID ETHICS ASIDE, HOW CAN HE BE
SO STUPID AS TO DO THAT TO THE
CIA -- IF YOU CHALLENGE THE CIA,
THEY HAVE SIX DIFFERENT WAYS TO
SUNDAY TO GET BACK AT YOU.
THE ENTIRE TRUMP PRESIDENCY WAS
DRIVEN BY ALL SORTS OF
NARRATIVES FROM THE MEDIA ABOUT
HOW THESE HEROIC, INDEPENDENT
GENERALS LIKE MATTIS AND
JOHN KELLY AND H.R. McMASTER
WERE GOING TO SAVE US FROM THE
ELECTED PRESIDENT AND THERE WERE
ALL KINDS OF REPORTS ABOUT HOW
SECURITY STATE OFFICIALS WOULD
CONCEAL CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
THEY DIDN'T WANT PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO HAVE IN ORDER TO MINDY
DELAYED HIS DECISION-MAKING OR
SUBVERT AND IGNORE HIS
DECISION-MAKING LIKED WHEN HE
WOULD TELL THEM TO WITHDRAW
TROOPS FROM SYRIA.
THIS WAS CELEBRATED AT THE SAME
TIME, THEY WOULD SAY IF YOU SAY
THERE IS A DEEP STATE IN THE
UNITED STATES WHICH IS NOTHING
MORE THAN WHAT DWIGHT EISENHOWER
WARNED ABOUT A PERMANENT POWER
FACTION IN WASHINGTON THAT RULES
THE COUNTRY REGARDLESS OF THE
OUTCOME OF ELECTIONS, THEY WOULD
TELL YOU YOU ARE CRAZY, YOU ARE
CONSPIRACY THEORY, EVEN AS YOU
ARE CHEERING FOR THE CLASSIC
DEFINITION OF THE DEEP STATE IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
YOU HAVE TO BE A CONSPIRACY
THEORIST OR INCREDIBLY GULLIBLE
NOT TO BELIEVE THAT EXISTS.
>> Tucker: HERE IS THE
EVIDENCE THAT WON ME OVER.
FAMOUSLY PEOPLE SAY YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO CRITICIZE, WHAT IS
THE ONE GROUP REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS NEVER CRITICIZE, THE
NATIONAL SECURITY STATE.
REPUBLICANS ARE HAPPY TO GO
AFTER THE IRS OR THE EDUCATION
DEPARTMENT, I CAN'T REMEMBER THE
LAST TIME A REPUBLICAN LEADER
MEANINGFULLY CRITICIZE THE DOJ
AND THE PENTAGON, DEMOCRATS ARE
EXACTLY THE SAME, THAT TELLS YOU
EVERYTHING, DOESN'T IT?
>> THE AMAZING THING IS FOR
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO POINT TO IN
DONALD TRUMP'S COMPORTMENT AND
GOVERNANCE WHICH I THINK ARE
SEVERAL VALID ONES, ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS THAT HE
DID WAS HE DEVIATED FROM THAT
CAGE THAT PRESIDENTS ARE KEPT
IN, HE TOLD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THERE ARE THE SECURITY STATE
AGENTS WHO THINK THEY RUN THE
GOVERNMENT AND HE STOOD UP TO
THEM AND CHALLENGE THEIR
ORTHODOXIES AND PIETIES AND
SHOWED AMERICANS ESPECIALLY
PEOPLE IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
ON THE RIGHT THAT THESE
INSTITUTIONS ARE NOT NOBLE OR
BENEVOLENT BUT ARE HIGHLY
PERNICIOUS, THEY WANT TO
INTERFERE IN OUR DOMESTIC
POLITICS AND THEY OUGHT TO BE
DEEPLY DISTRUSTED TO.
I THINK THAT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS HE DID AND IT
WAS FOR THAT REASON, HIS
WILLINGNESS TO CRITICIZE THEM
THAT THEY HATED HIM AND SPENT
FOUR YEARS TRYING TO UNDERMINE
HIS PRESIDENCY AND THE AMAZING
THING IS THEY ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
THE SANCTITY OF DEMOCRACY.
HOW WAS DEMOCRACY MORE
THREATENED THAN HAVING UNELECTED
PEOPLE WHO OPERATE IN THE DARK
FREE TO UNDERMINE AND SABOTAGE
THE PERSON THAT AMERICANS CHOSE
AS THEIR PRESIDENT?
>> Tucker: THANK YOU, EXACTLY.
IF YOU WANT TO WRECK DEMOCRACY,
THAT'S HOW YOU DO IT'S.
THERE'S A LOT OF EVIDENCE THE
LAST PRESIDENT WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT THEIR POWER ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL, HE UNDERSTOOD HOW
POWERFUL THEY ARE.
REALLY QUICK, DO YOU THINK AT
THIS STAGE IT WOULD BE POSSIBLE
FOR PRESIDENT TO PUSH BACK AND
TO STRIP THE UNELECTED POWER
CENTERS OF SOME OF THEIR POWER
IN THE GOVERNMENT?
>> YOU WOULD NEED A BIG ARMY
BEHIND YOU, THAT'S WHY PEOPLE
WERE PETRIFIED OF J. EDGAR
HOOVER, HE KEPT DOSSIERS ON
EVERY POLITICIAN THROUGHOUT
WASHINGTON.
YOU NEED THE POPULATION TO RISE
UP AGAINST THEM FOR THAT TO
WORK.
>> Tucker: I HOPE THAT
HAPPENS -- I THINK DEMOCRACY IS